[Música]
a través del tiempo mi perspectiva del
amar y de ser amado de la vida y de la
muerte el concepto de amor en pareja y
sobre todo cómo vivir la vida ha
cambiado totalmente hola me llamo víctor
bañuelos huang y hoy estoy aquí para
reflexionar en cómo elegimos estar
hace 8 años tuve un evento que me marcó
ese evento me hizo querer encontrar las
razones de muchas cosas como qué es la
felicidad qué es el éxito porque hay
personas más felices que otros a pesar
de no tener todo lo que quieren cómo
puedo ser mejor personal
todas estas dudas
extraña en mi mente aparte de esa
resumido una depresión profunda
empecé a buscar respuestas en muchos
lugares como la meditación el yoga
también los buscaban lugares de excesos
como las fiestas el sexo fui a retiros
espirituales a talleres de desarrollo
personal también fui con psicólogos o
conjuros espirituales algunas cosas
lograron calmar esa ansiedad o depresión
que traía otras solo a dejar más vacío
por dentro
está olvidando de lo más importante
con todo eso no estaba teniendo lo más
importante en mi vida yo
estaba buscando fuera de mí lo que desde
un inicio de vida haber encontrado ni
y tuvieron que pasar cuatro años en
depresión para que me pudiera dar cuenta
de eso
en el 2016 me tuvieron que operar por
segunda vez de una lesión de la columna
y un día saliendo de la rehabilitación
en la calle un joven con problemas de mi
playa
mentalmente agradecí por no tener esos
problemas de salud no fui a trabajar ya
por la tarde después de comer quisiera
descansar un poco
sólo logré llegar a la cama perdí la
movilidad de todo lado izquierdo no
podía hablar y solo saben mi hija
conmigo ella tiene parálisis cerebral
moderada
así que como pude ir le pedí que le
hablara a su hermano para que trataba de
pedir ayuda con sus seguros
ya cuando subo en el hospital les
cambian no servía
y tienen que volverlo programar los
factores ni idea de lo que me había
pasado un evento cerebrovascular
pero tenían que determinar que era lo
que tenía pues el medicamento para curar
un infarto
es muy diferente el medicamento que se
utiliza para un derrame cerebral
ya como las 11 de la noche no puede no
pueden hacer el estudio y descubrió que
yo había sufrido un infarto cerebral
después de todo eso se tuvieron que
parar del corazón para sacarme los
coágulos que tenía y así poder evitar
tener otro infarto
después de ese evento tuve que poner la
atención en mi vida
toda persona que ha sufrido que ha
tenido una operación a corazón abierto
tiene que ir con un psicólogo así que
volví ahí con mi terapeuta y psicóloga
me ha ayudado mucho
días antes del infarto había asistido un
grupo de desarrollo personal
y reflexionando sobre las distintas
ideas que me daban al coach pues en una
sesión yo le vi yo le decía que yo
quería ayudar a los demás que quería
viajar por todo el mundo osvaldo así se
llama mi coach me dijo que algo que es
muy ser muy cierto
dijo que no tengo que ir al final del
mundo para poder ayudar a la gente que
eso lo puedo hacer en mi propio país
posterior al infarto mucha gente no fue
a visitar nuestros amigos que hacía
mucho tiempo que no sabía nada de ellos
me buscaron otra vez y gracias a ellos
me di cuenta de cuando afortunado era al
contar con esa amistad de ellos asimismo
gracias a toda mi familia pues por ellos
y por su cuidado pudo hacer terapia
y pude recuperar parte del movimiento
que había perdido me acuerdo que muchos
que me visitaban me dicen mi misión en
esta vida aún no había terminado esas
palabras eran muy pesadas para mí la
sentía muy pesadas sentía mucha
responsabilidad por ese motivo y no me
sentía capaz de lograrlo pero ahora me
doy cuenta de que no es tan difícil como
parecía
y de que estoy en el lugar donde debo
estar soy maestro de la universidad de
mi estado
y en mis clases no sólo me enfoco a dar
la clase hablar el tema si alguien no
entiendo no entiende
comprendo que cada persona tiene su
propio ritmo y su propia manera de
aprender
así que vuelvo a explicar todo desde una
perspectiva diferente
trato de que se sientan parte de algo
con eso no nada más estoy viendo a mis
alumnos al dar mi clase estoy
transmitiendo un conocimiento que va a
ayudar a desenvolverse en un futuro a
esa persona pero también al escuchar a
ese alumno cuando se acerca a mí y me
cuenta sus problemas o sus motivos de
alegría estoy creando un plazo muy
importante de confianza al dar mi clase
no sólo transmite un conocimiento
también estoy transmitiendo valores esos
valores van a impactar en mi alumno y en
su familia directa
en un futuro cuando él tenga una familia
esa familia también estará influenciada
por esos valores ya su vez esa familia
podrá influir a otras familias e incluso
a la ciudad sociedad entera
en la que nos desenvolvemos con
frecuencia escucho a gente quejarse de
todo del gobierno del fútbol de la
economía de dios de su pareja hasta de
sí mismos
bueno pues desde que yo me di cuenta de
que quejarse solo te trae más
inconformidad de todo yo he decidido
sonreír hacer mi trabajo con alegría sé
que soy humano y tengo muchos errores
pero trato de irlo mejorando
dedico tiempo a mi salud física y mental
elijo ser un ser inteligente
emocionalmente ahora con mi discapacidad
logro entender un poco más la limitante
mi hija y eso me ayudó me ha dado más
paciencia hacia las personas que son
diferentes a mí
todo pasa por algo y después de todo lo
que he vivido aprendí que cada uno viene
a vivir su propia historia y lo más
importante es cumplir mis propias
expectativas
y no la de los demás
también aprendí que es mejor vivir con
una sonrisa
y disfrutar todo lo que vivo porque no
sé si lo podré volver a vivir no sufro
por lo que no tengo
no quisiera tener disfruto lo que tengo
y disfruto mucho mis amigos de mi
familia y de mi profesión trato de dejar
un mundo mejor
debe actuar trato de transmitir que no
importa que tan grande sea mi acción lo
que importa es que decido hacer algo
mejor por mi entorno y siempre trato de
hacerlo sonriendo agradeciendo la
oportunidad que tengo por aprender cada
día y crecer gracias
[Música]